Catedrática Tamar Gendler: Muy bien.
La clase pasada los dejé en suspenso
con esta diapositiva... Permítanme
comenzar rápidamente recordando
dónde nos quedamos la clase
pasada, terminar con eso
y después pasar a los temas de hoy.
Como recordarán, al final de la
clase pasada estaba hablando
de una crítica particular que los
psicólogos sociales contemporáneos
hacen a la teoría moral
de Aristóteles.
Recuerden que Aristóteles
tiene una teoría moral
cuya noción fundamental se basa en
la persona de buen carácter,
aquella que actúa como una
persona bien educada
y con sabiduría práctica.
Aristóteles llama a esa
persona frónimos.
En el ensayo que leímos de John
Doris, se aborda una cuestión
que varios filósofos han
expresado en los últimos años,
la preocupación de que la
teoría moral de Aristóteles
comete un error. Comete lo que
los psicólogos llaman
el error fundamental de la atribución.
Este error consiste en
considerar que el carácter
es el principal determinante de la
acción y no la circunstancia.
Doris realizó varios
estudios psicológicos
que pretendían demostrar que el
principal determinante de la acción
es la circunstancia y no un rasgo
destacado de la persona.
Nos explicó la historia de las
personas en la cabina de teléfono
y nos sugirió que lo que
determinaba si la gente ayudaba
era un rasgo local del estado de ánimo
y no un rasgo destacado del carácter.
Nos contó la historia del
estudio del buen samaritano,
sugiriendo otra vez que la
circunstancia o la situación
afectaban la conducta y no los
rasgos destacados del carácter.
Leímos y analizamos los
experimentos de Milgram:
circunstancias donde las
personas actúan de formas
que podrían considerarse atípicas.
Ya habíamos hablado y
volveremos a hablar
de la idea de la suerte moral:
que uno puede encontrarse
en circunstancias
que llevan a un
comportamiento
determinado.
Sin duda, la afirmación
de que la circunstancia es la
principal causante
de la conducta tiene algo de cierto.
Es indudable que hay
circunstancias que contribuyen
a la forma de actuar de la gente.
Pero considero que esa tendencia
de la psicología social
que enfatiza Doris es solo una
parte de la historia.
Además de que la circunstancia
contribuye al carácter,
existe un gran cuerpo de investigación
de la psicología de la
personalidad que estudia
una serie de rasgos que parecen
estar muy establecidos
en las personas durante su
primer año de vida.
Estos rasgos son bastante
estables en el tiempo
y terminan correlacionándose con
otra variedad de medidas.
Cosas como la apertura a
nuevas experiencias,
la escrupulosidad para cumplir
con las responsabilidades,
la extroversión a diferencia de la
introversión, la capacidad de
ser agradable y el neuroticismo (un
cierto tipo de ansiedad).
Aunque la circunstancia juega
un papel determinante
en la conducta de la gente,
también es cierto que la personalidad
individual hace su contribución.
Una de las evidencias más
espectaculares de esto
son los estudios de la demora de la
gratificación de Walter Mischel,
que explicaré ahora y más
adelante en la clase.
Parece que, si los estudios de Mischel
con miles de niños son confiables,
la capacidad temprana de autorregulación
o la demora de la gratificación
ante la tentación predicen
enormemente todo tipo de cosas,
desde resultados de exámenes de
admisión a la universidad
hasta relaciones sociales en la escuela.
Las funciones sociales y
cognitivas parecen correlacionarse
con ciertos rasgos de la
experiencia temprana.
Aunque es indudable que la
crítica situacionista
tiene algo de cierto y que
es un error pensar
que el carácter es el único
causante de la conducta y que
las características del entorno
no juegan ningún papel,
considero que tampoco es correcto
decir que solo la circunstancia
contribuye a la conducta
y que el individuo no.
Quienes estén interesados en ver
las diferencias individuales
en los niños, tal vez
quieran ver algunos videos
de los estudios de Mischel
donde hay niños sentados
frente a unos bombones
haciendo caras como esta,
esta, esta o esta.
Pobrecita, seguro tendrá baja
calificación en sus exámenes,
pero ese bombón le va a saber muy rico.
Quienes estén interesados en esto
aquí hay 3 distintas presentaciones
del caso de los bombones.
Subiré estas diapositivas
para que puedan verlas en Internet.
Ok. Así concluimos la última clase.
Hacemos una transición directa al
tema de la clase de hoy,
el tema con el que comenzamos
esta sección del curso: las
estrategias para autorregularnos ante
la debilidad de la voluntad.
En la clase pasada enfatizamos
la idea de Aristóteles
de qué se necesita para ser
una persona virtuosa.
Aristóteles decía que
para ser virtuoso
s necesario satisfacer 4 condiciones.
Es necesario saber qué es lo correcto,
decidir hacer lo correcto
porque es lo correcto,
hacerlo de forma estable
y sin ir en contra de las
propias inclinaciones.
Esas son las 4 condiciones necesarias
para ser virtuoso según Aristóteles.
Al otro lado del espectro de la virtud
en la noción aristotélica
se encuentra el vicio, que es
básicamente lo opuesto.
Es una clara tendencia
consciente, estable y armoniosa
de actuar precisamente de
forma incorrecta.
La persona viciosa
sabe lo que es incorrecto,
decide hacerlo porque es incorrecto,
lo hace de forma estable
y no siente ninguna
inclinación a hacer lo
correcto.
Esos son los dos extremos del
espectro aristotélico.
De hecho, hay dos cosas que se
encuentran un poco más allá
del espectro aristotélico.
Quienes consultaron la guía de
lectura saben de Aristóteles
también identifica la noción de un
estado muy afín al estado
que Jonathan Shay denomina el
estado enloquecido.
Aristóteles lo llama brutalidad,
un estado que está por debajo de
la virtud y del vicio.
Y da ejemplos de algunas
tragedias griegas
en las que se descuartiza un cuerpo
extremidad a extremidad.
Aristóteles considera que
es posible salirse
por completo del reino moral.
El vicio, según Aristóteles, sigue
siendo una forma de actuar
previsible y estable en el mundo.
Pero, la brutalidad se
encuentra por debajo de esto.
Y por encima de la virtud está
la divinidad: un estado
donde la regulación con respecto a la
virtud ni siquiera es necesaria.
Pero el meollo de la discusión
que leímos para hoy,
en el capítulo 7 del libro de
Ética de Aristóteles,
aborda este rango de estados
entre la virtud y el vicio.
Aristóteles proporciona una
taxonomía muy completa que
considero útil para entender cómo
alcanzar la autorregulación.
Quiero enfatizar que no soy ninguna
erudita sobre Aristóteles
y que lo que explico es una
reconstrucción artificial.
Pero pienso que es útil
para entender lo que
representan estas distinciones.
Primero podríamos preguntarnos,
cómo es el estado en el que hay virtud,
en el que se sabe qué es lo correcto
y se decide actuar así
porque es correcto
y se tiene la tendencia a actuar así, pero
no se tiene el tipo de carácter
o la estabilidad lógica
distintiva de la virtud
según Aristóteles.
Pienso que es el estado que
Aristóteles llama templanza.
Uno siente la inclinación a hacer lo
correcto porque es lo correcto.
Y uno sabe qué es lo correcto.
Pero no se tiene la estabilidad
de carácter previsible,
tipo ley, que exige la virtud.
Correspondiente a la templanza, al
otro lado de la escala,
está lo que Aristóteles
llama intemperancia,
que de cierta forma es la imagen
invertida de la templanza.
Aquí uno solo siente la
inclinación a hacer lo incorrecto
porque es lo incorrecto.
Pero no como un rasgo
fuerte del carácter
como sucede en el caso del vicio,
sino como una cuestión
del temperamento.
La persona templada, con
inclinación, hace lo correcto.
Tiene la inclinación a hacer lo
correcto y actúa de esa manera.
La persona inmoderada, con inclinación,
hace lo incorrecto y no siente
conflicto ante ello.
¿Qué pasa si eliminamos otro de
los rasgos aristotélicos?
¿Qué pasa si sabemos
qué es lo correcto
y decidimos hacer lo correcto,
pero nuestra inclinación
nos lleva en otra dirección?
Hemos tomado la decisión de
actuar según lo correcto,
por lo menos en un nivel
abstracto si no es que concreto,
sabemos lo que es correcto.
Aristóteles dice y yo pongo
esta aproximación
frente al conocimiento de que
"la persona moderada o
inmoderada reconoce
una regla general pero tiene cierta
dificultad para reconocer
si dicha regla es válida en
este caso en particular".
La persona moderada sabe
qué es lo correcto,
ha tomado la decisión de
actuar según lo correcto,
pero su inclinación la lleva
en otra dirección.
Le cuesta trabajo evitar el
pastel de chocolate.
Le cuesta trabajo levantarse
cuando suena su alarma.
Le cuesta trabajo no comerse
el primer bombón
para poder recibir el segundo.
Pero de alguna forma se contiene y
actúa en contra de su inclinación.
Para Aristóteles, la imagen
invertida de la persona moderada
es la persona inmoderada.
En cuanto a su decisión, es
como la persona moderada.
Quiere hacer lo que corresponde
según la moralidad.
Al igual que la persona moderada,
tiene conciencia de la regla general,
pero tiene un poco de dificultad
para ver cómo se aplica
en este caso particular.
Al igual que la persona moderada,
tiene la inclinación de ir hacia
un placer que le atrae.
Pero a diferencia de la
persona moderada,
la inmoderada no es capaz de
dominar su inclinación.
Y, por debajo de la línea,
actúa según lo incorrecto.
Por último, Aristóteles
considera un par de casos
donde la atracción de
hacer lo incorrecto
no es un placer deseado, sino un
deseo de evitar el dolor.
En algunos casos, no tenemos todo el
mérito por ser moderados,
no nos resistimos a los placeres, pero
estamos dispuestos a aguantar
cierta incomodidad para
hacer lo correcto.
Aristóteles denomina a esta
resistencia: moderación ante el dolor.
Correspondiente a eso, por debajo de la
línea, se encuentra la debilidad,
la falta de moderación ante el dolor.
Hacer lo incorrecto porque
hemos cedido a cierto tipo
de incomodidad.
Les pongo esta lista
porque pienso que no queda muy
claro al leer la primera vez,
ni la segunda, ni la tercera, ni
la cuarta en el Libro VII
de Ética de Aristóteles lo bien
estructurada que está la idea aristotélica
del alma humana, sus
fortalezas y debilidades.
Pienso que si la vemos como una serie
de características apareadas,
donde cada una tiene
o carece de ciertos rasgos de la virtud
aristotélica paradigmática,
entonces podemos entender mejor
el panorama aristotélico.
Los invito a que con este marco
vuelvan a leer el texto que hemos
leído tantas veces en esta clase:
el que está al final del Libro I
y al principio del Libro II de
Ética de Aristóteles.
Y vuelvan a intentar
ver la imagen de la virtud que
Aristóteles propone.
En lo que resta de la clase de hoy
quiero explicar la idea de
Aristóteles de la falta de
moderación.
Vamos a necesitar nuestros
clickers muy pronto.
¿Qué significa estar en una
situación en la que sabemos
qué es lo correcto en lo abstracto?
En la que nos comprometemos a
hacer lo correcto.
Pero en la que nuestra inclinación
nos lleva en otra dirección
y cedemos a esa inclinación.
Quiero comenzar preguntando
cuál opción prefieren.
Esto es una encuesta real.
Aquí tengo el dinero, en este sobre.
Y aquí tengo, no estoy bromeando,
una lista de los alumnos de la clase.
Y mientras responden a esta
pregunta, voy a cerrar mis ojos
y seleccionar un nombre de la lista.
Ahora les pregunto.
Tienen 10 segundos para decidir una vez
que comience el cronómetro.
Uno de ustedes de verdad se va
a llevar 5 USD ahora
o 6 USD el jueves.
Y podrías ser tú.
Ok. Saquen los clickers. Nos
quedan 10 segundos.
Ok. Veamos las respuestas de esto.
Ok. El 22% quiere 5 USD ahora.
El 78% quiere 6 USD dentro de 2 días.
¿Sarah Cox? ¿Sarah Cox, estás aquí?
Sarah Cox, ¿qué elegiste?
Alumna: [inaudible].
Catedrática Tamar Gendler: Ok.
Guardaré esto aquí,
en mi libro de Ética de Aristóteles
para cumplir con mi palabra.
Ok. Sin embargo, el 22% se habría
llevado el sobre en este momento.
Bien, segunda pregunta.
¿Cuál eligen? Otra vez tengo dinero.
Tengo otro sobre.
Está en mi bolsa.
Pueden elegir 5 USD en 35
días o 6 USD en 37.
¿De acuerdo? 5 USD en 35
La votación está abierta.
10 segundos.
10, 9, 8... 5 USD en 35 días.
6 USD en 37 días.
Veamos los resultados.
Ok. Muy bien.
Ustedes ejemplifican muy bien el aspecto
del error experimental de
apretar botones en esto.
O tal vez, algunos de ustedes perciben
esta opción como distinta.
Bien, el 20% prefería 5 USD hoy,
en vez de 6 USD el jueves,
aunque casi nadie
quería tomar la misma
decisión dentro de un mes.
Déjenme destacar algo que es
completamente obvio
para la parte racional de sus almas.
Estas opciones son idénticas.
Les ofrecí 5 USD el día 15
o 6 USD el día 17.
O les ofrecí 5 USD el día 22
o 6 USD el día 24.
Cuando se trata del 22
marzo, el 22% de ustedes
que dio distintas respuestas
en estos 2 casos,
estarán exactamente en la
misma situación de ahora,
de tener 5 USD o 6 USD.
No hay diferencia entre una
opción y la otra.
Sin embargo, suele darse el caso
de que sistemáticamente
los humanos y los animales no
humanos tienen la tendencia
a actuar distinto cuando las
recompensas demoradas
se presentan en un futuro lejano
o en un futuro cercano.
Durante décadas, el
psicólogo George Ainslie
ha estudiado decisiones con la
siguiente estructura.
Una decisión entre una recompensa
menor que se obtiene antes,
como los 5 USD o los 6 USD, y
otra recompensa mayor
que se obtiene más tarde. Ainslie
ha analizado este fenómeno
en humanos y animales no humanos.
Les voy a leer una cita,
que estará en las
diapositivas en Internet,
donde se brinda una idea de lo que
representa este fenómeno.
Ainslie lo llama descuento
hiperbólico. Y dice:
"A veces, las personas, y siempre,
los animales inferiores,
descartan la posibilidad de
recompensas futuras en una curva
que está más pronunciada que una
curva racional exponencial".
Es perfectamente racional
descartar recompensas futuras
si hay cierta duda, ¿verdad?
Si les ofreciera 5 USD ahora
o 6 USD en 20 años,
tendría todo el sentido
tomar los 5 USD ahora
debido a que el grado de
incertidumbre de obtener 6 USD
es muy grande comparado con el
grado de incertidumbre
de obtener 5 USD ahora.
Espero que la diferencia
entre pensar si ustedes
y yo estaremos en este
salón este jueves
o el jueves dentro de 3
semanas sea insignificante.
Ainslie continúa: "en un
rango de demoras,
desde segundos hasta décadas,
hay pares de recompensas
alternativas donde los sujetos
prefieren la recompensa
menor y más cercana
en vez de la mayor
cuando la demora de la
menor será breve".
Por ejemplo, los que preferían 5 USD
hoy en lugar de 6 USD el jueves.
"Pero prefieren la recompensa
mayor y más lejana
cuando la alternativa más
pequeña se retrasará más".
5 USD en 35 días contra 6
USD en 37 días.
"Aunque el tiempo entre la primera
y la segunda recompensa
sea el mismo.
Las curvas que mejor se ajustan
a los datos observados
son hiperbólicas.
Muestran que los valores
son inversamente
proporcionales a la
demora".
Lo que pasa es que
para un periodo de tiempo, A,
se prefiere la recompensa
mayor a la menor.
Esos son ustedes.
En 37 días. En 36 días. En
35 días. En 34 días.
Durante este tiempo, prefieren 6
USD dos días más tarde
que 5 USD ahora, o 5 USD
dos días antes.
De repente, a medida que el
acontecimiento se acerca,
el valor de la recompensa menor
les parece más grande.
Todas las decisiones tienen
esta estructura.
Supongamos que quieren entrenarse para
ser ciclistas profesionales,
o cualquier otra actividad atlética,
esa es su recompensa
mayor y más lejana.
Supongamos que una cosa incompatible
con su meta de ser
ciclistas profesionales
es comer panqués.
Van caminando por ahí y al
principio tienen muy claro
que prefieren ser ciclistas.
Despiertan un día y dicen:
"Voy a hacer un plan para
andar en bicicleta.
No me voy a distraer con
tonterías como los panqués".
Comienzan a caminar,
todavía consideran que la
recompensa de la bicicleta es mayor
que la recompensa del panqué.
De repente, a medida que se
acercan al panqué,
toman la recompensa más
cercana y menor;
y la mayor y más lejana
desaparece de sus posibilidades.
Supongamos que deciden que
mañana se van a levantar
muy temprano para escribir su ensayo
de la clase de Filosofía 181,
también llamada Ciencias
Cognitivas 281.
Ponen su alarma y configuran el tono.
Cuando se van a dormir la
ponen para las 5:30 am.
Pueden ver que esa recompensa mayor y
más lejana es más importante.
Dan las 5:30 am y la alarma suena. La
apagan pero no se levantan.
Acaban con su posibilidad de la
recompensa mayor y más lejana.
O supongamos que son uno de los sujetos
del estudio de los bombones de Mischel.
Aquí está su recompensa mayor y
más lejana: dos bombones.
Aquí está su recompensa más
pequeña y más cercana: un bombón.
Pregúntense en lo abstracto,
¿están seguros de que es mejor
tener dos bombones que
uno?, ¿hasta cuándo?
Hasta que están en una sala con
el bombón, se lo comen
y pierden su otra oportunidad.
En el resto de la clase de hoy
quiero hablar un poco del estado
psicológico de los niños
que participaron en los estudios de
Mischel y después unir esto
con investigaciones más generales
sobre la autorregulación.
Y por último, conectar eso con la
discusión de los principios
que teníamos en nuestra
lectura de Nozick para hoy.
Cuando Walter Mischel comenzó con
sus estudios de bombones,
hace 40 años aproximadamente,
había una teoría de que la mejor forma
de autorregularnos era
pensar en la recompensa
que obtendríamos si
hacíamos lo correcto.
Según esa teoría, la mejor
forma para que los niños
pudieran resistirse al primer bombón
y consiguieran los 2 bombones
sería que el experimentador les
explicara de forma muy creíble
que si esperaban, podrían
tener 2 bombones.
Los niños llegaron a la sala en
una de las 2 condiciones.
En una condición, había
un bombón cerca
y dos bombones lejos.
Las recompensas eran visibles.
Los niños entraron y tardaron, en
promedio, 4 minutos aproximadamente
en agarrar el bombón solo
y por lo tanto,
perdieron el segundo bombón.
Sin embargo, cuando las
recompensas estaban ocultas,
cuando los niños no
podían ver los bombones
y estaban en la sala y les decían
que podían tener un bombón
ahora o si esperaban lo
suficiente podrían tener dos,
los niños esperaron, en
promedio, 12 minutos.
Mischel se preguntaban qué motivaba
la capacidad de autocontrol
de los niños cuando las
recompensas estaban ocultas
para aguantar el tiempo suficiente.
La segunda condición que probó
consistía en decirle a los niños
que estaban en la circunstancia
donde las recompensas
estaban ocultas que pensaran
intensamente en la recompensa,
que pensaran con todas sus
fuerzas en esos bombones.
El efecto de pensar
fuertemente en los bombones
hizo que su desempeño cayera
exactamente al mismo nivel
que tenían los niños con las
recompensas visibles.
De hecho, pensar en la
recompensa en los casos
donde estaban visibles no
empeoró el comportamiento.
El problema era que al
pensar en la recompensa,
se volvía más relevante y era
más difícil resistirse.
Entonces, Mischel decidió
intentar lo contrario.
¿Qué pasaría si a los niños que
tienen la recompensa visible
les pedimos que piensen en
otra cosa que les guste?
Que vean hacia otros lados de la
sala, que digan el abecedario,
que se cuenten la historia de
los tres cochinitos,
que hagan algo para distraerse.
El resultado era que si los niños
pensaban en otras cosas
para distraerse, actuaban igual
que los niños con las
recompensas ocultas.
Pensar en otras distracciones
no hizo diferencia
cuando las recompensas estaban ocultas.
La presencia de la tentación en
la mente es, en parte,
lo que hace difícil resistirse a ella.
De hecho, Mischel pensó en esto
de forma más general.
Mostró a los niños una
fotografía o un bombón de verdad,
sin importar cuál,
les pedía que pensaran que era de
verdad y que se imaginaran
su sabor, que pensaran en lo
delicioso que sería.
Y los niños solo pudieron
imponerse una demora
de 6 minutos en promedio.
Por otra parte, cuando les
mostraba un bombón de verdad
les pedía que pensaran
que era imaginario,
que pensaron sobre él de
forma abstracta,
que pensaran en la cantidad de
bombones que había,
en la letra con que empezaba
la palabra bombón,
en la naturaleza de una dulcería
y cómo funcionaba en un
sentido abstracto.
¡Pero solo son niños de 4 años!
Los niños pudieron
autorregularse durante 18
minutos.
¿Qué estaba pasando?
Cómo se explican los casos donde
obtenemos cantidades muy bajas:
los niños solo pueden
aguantar 4 minutos
y después caen en la tentación.
¿Cómo se explican los casos donde
obtenemos cantidades grandes?
La hipótesis de Mischel, que
cuadra con el texto
que discutimos el 20 de enero,
es que hay 2 sistemas
para procesar las recompensas.
Hay un sistema caliente que actúa en
lo que Platón o Aristóteles
llamarían apetito o espíritu.
Actúa basado en la pasión.
Cuando pensamos en las cosas
con una atracción
emocional e intensa, se activa ese
sistema y también se activan
los caballos de Platón, las partes no
racionales de Aristóteles,
el sistema uno, los aliefs y todo eso.
Ese es el sistema que está
activo cuando las recompensas
están visibles y no hay
ninguna instrucción.
Cuando se piensa intensamente
en las recompensas,
las partes apetitivas del
alma se activan
y es difícil resistirse
a la tentación.
Por el contrario, cuando se le pide
a los niños que piensen
de forma abstracta o que piensen que
el bombón es imaginario,
se activa un sistema frío y racional:
un sistema relacionado con la
creencia, con el auriga de Platón,
con el sistema dos de la tradición
del procesamiento doble,
con la creencia en la
tradición del alief -creencia.
Este sistema de procesamiento frío
nos proporciona cierta distancia
racional con lo que nos enfrentamos
y la autorregulación se vuelve posible.
Los estudios de Mischel entran en un
marco de pensamiento más grande
acerca de cómo superar la tentación.
No les sorprenderá saber que
dicho marco está explicado,
al igual que casi todo lo que
analizamos en este curso,
en una de las dos grandes
narrativas que fundan
la tradición literaria
occidental: La Odisea de Homero.
Aquí está Odiseo muy elegante
con una túnica blanca
intentando volver a casa tras
la guerra de Troya.
Está intentando volver con su
esposa que lo espera fielmente
en su casa, pero está tardando
como 20 años en lograrlo.
En su viaje, en su intento por
llegar a casa, se enfrenta
a todo tipo de tentaciones que
amenazan con desviarlo de su camino.
En esta imagen se enfrenta
a la tentación
de estas hermosas mujeres que
vuelan, que a mí me recuerdan
un poco a los dementores
de Harry Potter.
Sin embargo, él las considera
sumamente tentadoras.
Y está intentando buscar la forma de que
el barco ignore a las sirenas,
cuyas canciones amenazan con hundirlo,
para llegar a casa con Penélope.
Y se le ocurren dos estrategias.
La primera estrategia es
para sus marineros.
Verán que todos tienen cubiertos
sus oídos con algodón.
Les tapa los oídos para que
la supuesta influencia
de las sirenas sea menor.
Si no pueden escuchar su canción,
los marineros podrán
continuar remando el barco
y podrán pasar la fuente
de la tentación.
Como pueden ver, ubicado en el punto
A de la curva de Ainslie,
él mismo se ha atado al mástil.
Porque igual que los niños de
Mischel y que Ainslie,
sabe que si la canción de las
sirenas le llega directo,
estará en ese estado B
en el que la recompensa menor y
más cercana parece mayor,
como en el ejemplo de apagar su alarma
o el de comerse el panqué.
Entonces, Odiseo se ata al mástil.
Aunque la tentación de la
recompensa es evidente para él,
se ha declarado incapaz de actuar en
contra de esa tentación.
Hay una tradición en la literatura de la
teoría de la decisión contemporánea
de usar esta metáfora de Ulises
u Odiseo y las sirenas,
dependiendo de qué
traducción del nombre se use,
para pensar en estrategias
de autorregulación.
Y considero que es útil pensar
en estas estrategias
organizadas en 3 categorías.
Si están intentando superar una
tentación que tiene la misma estructura
que hemos visto en esta clase: una
recompensa menor y más cercana
que debido al descuento temporal,
crece de forma desproporcionada
en su estructura de decisión.
Una forma de sortearla es mediante
restricciones externas.
Pueden quitarse la capacidad de
actuar sobre la tentación.
Pueden apagar el Internet en su
computadora, pueden usar
uno de esos condones para
celulares, pueden declararse
incapaces de actuar ante aquello que
los distrae de su camino.
Pueden poner su alarma en el
otro extremo cuarto,
pueden evitar tener panqués en
sus casas, pueden poner
su tarjeta de crédito en un vaso
con agua en el congelador.
Todas estas son formas
de quitarse la capacidad de
actuar sobre la tentación.
O pueden separarse del atractivo de la
tentación de alguna manera.
Pueden reducir la utilidad
subjetiva que tiene para ustedes,
por ejemplo, tapando sus oídos
para que ni siquiera noten que la
tentación está ahí.
Es una forma de exteriorizar
la responsabilidad
de la toma de decisiones en este caso.
Es una forma muy efectiva de
autorregulación.
Ustedes son agentes en el mundo.
Las acciones que van a realizar son
acciones sobre el mundo.
Quitarse la capacidad de
realizar dichas acciones
es una forma de sortear la tentación.
Otra forma de sortear la tentación,
que hemos discutido mucho en las
últimas dos clases, es mediante
la apelación directa a las partes
animadas o apetitivas de sus almas.
Pueden manipular las estructuras de
incentivos para ustedes mismos.
Pueden cambiar la utilidad relativa
de las diversas recompensas.
Pueden someterse a
presiones interpersonales.
Recuerden que pusimos las caritas
felices en sus computadoras
para que la mirada de los otros les
ayudara a ceñirse a sus tareas.
¿O pueden cultivar hábitos, verdad?
Pueden alinear el espíritu y el
apetito con la razón
cultivando formas naturales de
responder a las cosas.
Pero la tercera forma de
sortear las tentaciones,
que aún no hemos discutido,
es mediante la razón.
Es bajo esta luz que Nozick
discute los papeles
que pueden jugar los principios para
impedirnos ser inmoderados.
Nozick señala que, por lo general,
los principios agrupan acciones
colocándolas bajo un título general
para que las acciones relacionadas
sean vistas o tratadas igual.
Si uno tiene el principio de ser
vegetariano, cualquier acción
de comer carne es vista como una
violación a dicho principio.
Aunque uno piense que hay circunstancias
en las que comer carne
podría ser lo correcto.
El principio clasifica este acto
con otros actos de comer
carne, de tal forma
que las acciones se vuelven
simbólicas de otra acción.
Fumar solo un cigarro no es tan
malo, pero fumar muchos sí.
Un principio les permite
tener una postura
que sirve de ejemplo para todo.
Los principios, dice Nozick, son una
forma de atarnos al mástil,
no mediante restricciones externas
como las cuerdas sino a través
de compromisos internos para
cumplir con nuestros mandatos.
Y destaca que los principios son
efectivos en una variedad de casos.
Intelectualmente, si tienes la
idea de que hay un principio
que conecta una serie de
hechos con otra,
entonces el principio puede
transmitir probabilidad o apoyo.
Los casos antiguos se dieron de
una forma particular.
Cada vez que observaban un
cierto tipo de causalidad,
tenía una estructura particular.
Identificaban un principio y
después estaban en la posición
de hacer predicciones
sobre nuevos casos.
Interpersonalmente, les
permiten ser percibidos
como personas confiables.
Sus acciones pasadas fueron
de cierta manera.
Cada vez que les dije que les
daría dinero, les di dinero.
Ustedes pueden concluir con base en
eso que tengo un principio:
pagar mis deudas.
Y con base en eso predicen
mis futuras acciones.
De hecho, precisamente por eso,
cambié todos los ejercicios
escritos a los jueves,
en vez de dar extensiones para algunos.
Pensé que si ya había dado extensiones
para dos ensayos de martes a jueves,
parecería que no tengo principios
sobre las normas de este curso.
¿Cómo podría hacer cumplir
los requisitos del curso
si parece que no tengo principios?
Supongamos que adopto un
nuevo principio,
la fecha de entrega en jueves,
con respecto al cual me mantengo firme.
Recapacito un momento.
Extrañamente, eso parece tener más
autoridad que tener la mayoría
con fecha de entrega el martes
y algunos en jueves.
Intrapersonalmente, conceptualizarnos
en términos de principios
brinda una especie de continuidad
narrativa a nuestras vidas.
Mi yo pasado era una persona
que nunca haría X.
Mi yo pasado es una persona
que siempre hace Y.
Expresar esto en términos
de un principio
me permite conectar mi yo
futuro con mi yo pasado.
Me da una sensación de
continuidad en el tiempo.
Y por último, intrapersonalmente,
los principios proporcionan formas
de vencer la tentación.
Cada vez que veo un panqué
me lo quiero comer,
pero si tengo un principio
de no comer postre
después de las 4:00 pm,
entonces es fácil.
No tengo que tomar una
decisión para cada caso.
El acto de comer ese panqué
una vez me hace pensar:
¿Por qué esa vez? ¿Por qué
no hacerlo siempre?
Y eso se convierte en una
forma de comprometerme
conmigo mismo a acciones futuras.
Quienes toquen algún instrumento
saben que lo más fácil es
practicar todos los días.
Porque si practican todos los días,
no tienen que pensar si
hoy practican o no.
Si están comprometidos con un cierto
tipo de comportamiento religioso,
con una restricción alimenticia o
con una rutina de ejercicios,
la forma más fácil de
implementarlo es hacerlo siempre.
En esos temas, siempre me
voy a comportar así.
De hecho, Nozick sugiere que
esa es precisamente
la forma de usar los principios para
superar la curva de Ainslie.
El objetivo de un principio, dice
Ainslie, es relacionar
la decisión de hacer un acto
particular inmediato con toda una clase
de acciones que según el principio
están en la misma categoría.
Este acto ahora representa
a toda la clase.
He descubierto que estoy
usando en exceso
una sustancia relajante los
fines de semana.
La forma más directa para
enfrentarme a esta situación
es establecer una restricción
terminante a mi comportamiento.
Además, señala Nozick,
puedo usar una irracionalidad muy
interesante sobre mí mismo
para luchar irracionalmente
con la irracionalidad.
Recuerden que hace algunas
clases les dije que la gente
que pierde un billete de 10
USD de camino al cine,
saca otro para comprar otra
entrada cuando llega ahí.
Pero la gente que perdió una
entrada para el cine
con un valor de 10 USD, no
quiere comprar otra.
Este es un ejemplo de un
fenómeno general
conocido como costos hundidos:
cuando hemos invertido mucho
esfuerzo en algo,
nos resistimos a dejar de
actuar de acuerdo con ello,
aunque en ese momento
preferiríamos no hacerlo.
Nozick propone que si durante A,
ese periodo que sube en la
curva de Ainslie,
invertimos muchos recursos en el futuro
para alcanzar una recompensa mayor,
nuestra tendencia a no ignorar
los costos hundidos
nos proporciona una forma de
superar la tentación
durante el periodo B, para elegir la
recompensa menor y más cercana.
Si decido que quiero ir a 6
películas en el año
y compro 6 entradas,
aunque esté lloviendo una noche
en la que tendría que ir,
mi tendencia hacia los costos hundidos
me ayudará a realizar mi acción.
Bien, nos quedan 2 minutos.
Voy a conectar esto con lo que hemos
hecho y con lo que haremos.
Ya saben que esta es la última clase
de la primera unidad del curso.
Comenzamos esta unidad leyendo el
popular capítulo del libro
Predictably Irrational de Dan Ariely
y terminamos la unidad
leyendo el mismo capítulo
de procrastinación.
A diferencia de su
experiencia del 11 de enero,
ahora tienen un marco filosófico
para ubicar su discusión.
A diferencia del 11 de enero,
ahora tienen un marco psicológico
para ubicar su discusión.
Han leído a Haidt, a Batson, los
trabajos del procesamiento doble,
a Milgram, a Shay, a
Stockdale y a Kazdin.
Han leído su propia
presentación científica del
caso
y han reflexionado sobre las
conexiones entre ellos.
¿Qué sigue? Ahora tienen
la oportunidad,
en sus ejercicios dirigidos
5 y 6, de abordar
tres artículos de psicología que
ustedes elijan, tienen que resumirlos
y después pensar en un
experimento basándose en ellos.
Ahora tienen la oportunidad de
reflexionar sobre el marco filosófico
escribiendo sus primeros dos ensayos.
Y al final del curso, les
aviso desde ahora,
tendrán la oportunidad de
analizar las conexiones
entre ellos en el contexto de
nuestro ejercicio dirigido final.
Que será diseñar una semana
del curso ustedes mismos:
elegirán los textos que consideren
que explican el tema de varias maneras.
En nuestra siguiente clase pasaremos a
la discusión de la moralidad.
Y volveremos a conectar
con algunos temas
que hemos estado abordando hasta ahora.
Espero verlos el jueves
y sobre todo tengo ganas de
regalar los 6 USD
a la alumna racional que tuvo la
suerte de ganárselos.